there is no greater indictment I think
of our understanding of Truth and Law
And Justice and the way Society is
supposed to work
then the modern Elite University
commencement addresses
in the 18th century and 19th century
into the early 20th century
the top universities Harvard Yale
Princeton
they're a commencement ceremonies would
involve graduates
making arguments and giving speeches in
Latin Greek
Hebrew
they would have disputations they would
have extemporary
discourses on Broad questions of
metaphysics on the nature of the soul
and the nature of the human person on
the nature of the good now
the commencement ceremonies at all of
these schools up to and including
Harvard involve
Hollywood stars and Comedians and
entertainers
giving glib speeches about nothing
enter into this milia Tom Hanks at
Harvard over the weekend
we are all in a cage match
mixed martial arts Battle Royale
with agents of hubris apathy intolerance
and brain incompetence the malevolent
equals to Imperial Stormtroopers Lex
Luthor and Loki
and we could all use a superhero right
now the language of telling the truth it
is the in The Vision Quest for truth
that we look to you newly Incorporated
members of the Justice League of
Avengers
to come to the rescue
for the truth to some is no longer
empirical it's no longer Based on data
nor Common Sense nor even common decency
telling the truth is no longer The
Benchmark for public service it's no
longer the South to our fears or the
guide to our actions
truth is now considered malleable
by opinion and by zero-sum end games but
the truth
the truth is sacred
unalterable
chiseled into the stone of the
foundation of our Republic
this is a guy who thinks men can be
women
this is a guy who thinks that babies
aren't babies when
mommies wish that they weren't babies
this guy
lecturing us about the sanctity of the
truth
scolding us for having people in our
society who think the truth can be
malleable
this is the guy who in his practical
views in society
does not acknowledge truth whatsoever
and he doesn't even know that
I am quite confident Tom Hanks
is not in the least conscious
of the contradiction between what he's
saying at Harvard
and
how he behaves in the world
part of the reason I'm confident that
he's not aware of this is that he's
giving a commencement address at Harvard
and the
most soaring rhetoric that he can muster
is about superhero movies
he doesn't draw on literary figures
allegories that have existed in our
culture for Millennia deep philosophical
principles is it Harvard Harvard's
supposed to be a good school
the the deepest Wells of wisdom that he
can find are
Marvel movies
that's probably true for many of the
graduates in that audience too
probably true for many of the professors
in that audience too
that's Harvard
that's supposed to be one of the top
schools
how on Earth are we supposed to have a
serious Society grounded in truth
if these are our Elites
I'm sympathetic to Tom hanks's I think
sincere longing for a society grounded
on truth and Justice he just doesn't
know a damn thing about any of those
things and unfortunately neither do any
of the other members of our ruling class
which is why we need a new Elite
and the new Elite
ought to be drawn
according to the desires of the Common
People much more than from the current
Elite because we're in this weird place
today where the common people you know
the hoi polloi the unwashed masses they
get things a lot more than the current
Elite do
Target and transheiser Bush and all the
rest of them who want to trans the three
months olds
they've lost the plot
and the common unwashed people who don't
have fancy degrees from Harvard
generally
at the very least they know you
shouldn't trans the kids
at the very least they know generally
the babies are babies
that's
where the support for a new Elite is
going to have to come from right now go
to puretalk.com Knowles do you remember
the last time you got a free phone
started out feeling great right and then
came the Hefty activation fees the four
line requirements and of course that
binding contract Pure Talk is giving you
a free 5G Samsung Galaxy phone without
the feeling that you've been duped when
you switch to Pure talks unlimited talk
and text data plan that comes with a
mobile hotspot you will get a 5G Samsung
Galaxy for free that's right unlimited
everything at a fraction of the price of
Verizon ATT or T-Mobile here's another
thing you'll be on America's Most
Dependable 5G Network how do I know
because I am a customer make the switch
to Pure Talk the cell phone Wireless
company and I'm proud to stand behind
because one they have a great service
and two they're proud to stand behind
our mission at the daily wire puretalk's
us-based customer service team will help
you make the switch in as little as 10
minutes and you can even keep your phone
number go to puretalk.com
for your free Samsung Galaxy when you
sign up for unlimited talk text and
unlimited data puretalk.com Knowles Pure
Talk Wireless for Americans by Americans
now speaking of Harvard Law
people
speaking of Harvard Harvard undergrad
too I think Chuck Schumer I believe is a
double Harvard graduate tells you
everything you need to know Chuck
Schumer is very very upset
that the Maga Supreme Court is attacking
the environment
the Democrat leader of the senate senate
majority leader says quote this Maga
Supreme Court is continuing to erode
our country's environmental laws make no
mistake this ruling will mean more
polluted water and more destruction of
wetlands we'll keep fighting to protect
our Waters
this in response to a Supreme Court
decision on the epa's authority in
regulating certain properties and
Schumer's furious at the Maga Supreme
Court
and the Supreme Court right now is
five four or six three conservative
versus liberal depends on how you
classify chief justice Roberts who is a
big squish and he often sides with the
libs but he sometimes sides with the
conservatives so
however you cut it
it he it's a majority conservative Court
but this decision on the EPA
on the regulation of these Wetlands it
was a unanimous decision
all of the Court's liberals backed the
decision here
to say the EPA does not have
jurisdiction to regulate these
particular wetlands
does Chuck Schumer not know that
Harvard Law graduate as you probably
know that Senate majority leaders you
should probably know that or is he just
lying
does he just feel that he has to be
dishonest he has no reason to be honest
here and he's just going to lie truth be
damned
probably the latter
well that's not going to instill a lot
of confidence in our systems and
institutions of government right it's
always Chuck Schumer who's preening and
whining about January 6th people the
undermining our belief and in our sacred
elections this is the same
Chuck Schumer who stood outside of the
Supreme Court and said we're coming for
you justice Kavanaugh we're coming for
you justice Gorsuch that was of course
before a liberal tried to assassinate
Justice Kavanaugh at his home that was
before the conservative justices had to
leave their homes and flee because a
liberal leaked to Supreme Court decision
in Dobbs to try to Gin up an attack
against the conservatives
that was that was before all of that but
now and this is the same Chuck Schumer
who lies about what the Supreme Court
did
but now they Preen and they whine and
they say oh no the the terrible threat
to our institutions of government
they don't care about this stuff and so
I Injustice anywhere is a threat to
Justice everywhere
when these people
lie and they misrepresent and they
exaggerate
they are they're following their own
lights in that they don't really believe
in any background principles of Truth
and justice but that is going to
compromise our stable Society everywhere
else boy what a great clip that was make
sure you ring the bell and subscribe to
the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
we'll see you next time